we need a better media I I'm not bullish
on that idea and we need better
political leaders and it's hard to get
good political leaders because the media
is so biased because the culture has
gotten so rotten good decent people
don't want to get involved and I mean
that at the citizen level and I mean it
at the political level but every now and
again some people step up one of those
people who has stepped up is the creator
of the libs of tick tock a Twitter
account her name is Haya raychik people
did not know her name for a long time as
you know she was suspended by Twitter
many times when the Twitter files came
out she was one of the accounts that was
repeatedly suspended and banned and they
never had a specific reason why all this
girl does is she finds these crazy
gender activists who are often
Elementary School teachers she finds
their Tick Tock videos of how they're
indoctrinating kids and then she reposts
them often without comment so she's just
taking their stuff and showing it to
other people but for showing what
they're saying themselves she has been
called a homophobe and a transform and a
racist and everything else but she is
someone who stepped up in the middle of
this insane culture War she got involved
and then when she stepped up somebody
else who I've talked about once or twice
on this show decided to help her out uh
here she is with Tucker Carlson just a
couple days ago talking about just that
I will say this when I was doxed
um someone from Ron DeSantis whose team
calls me really yes and she said the
governor wanted me to give you a message
he said if you don't feel safe or you or
your family if you need a place to go to
hide to say you're you can come to the
governor's mansion what that we have a
guest house for you and you could come
and stay as long as you need
the governor of Florida yes I I can't
even I was like I was almost in tears
like the governor of Florida like he's
nothing but like and you're living I'm
living in California and he took time
out of his I'm assuming extremely busy
schedule you think I mean he's the
governor of Florida and to send someone
to call me to make sure I'm safe
you see what I'm saying this idea that
if you step up you can Inspire other
people to step up well that's just a
very granular example of that right
there she started doing the right thing
the media big Tech everybody went after
her the worst sort of hit pieces doxing
her all sorts of awful stuff and then
the governor of a state on the polar
opposite side of the country 3000 miles
away of which she is not a resident says
hey if you're in trouble we'll help you
out you'll be safe over here so that's
her stepping up it's him stepping up and
then what that also is is that other
people start seeing it and other people
get it in there get it they get it in
their pores like man you got to do some
things for yourself